Jeff if they have cut you loose and
allowed you to get back to writing
something do the creative stuff go run
flee so Jeff Jones is no longer in his
position at the executive level of DC
Comics and DC Entertainment this this is
something I might not have talked about
before but it happened in conjunction
with something else and I'll get to that
in a second
historically I have basically shaken my
fist at Warner Brothers telling them to
either allow Jeff Jones a level of
control akin to Kevin Feige which he
didn't seem to have there's always word
of higher executive level meddling and
Warner Brothers always and they said and
if they weren't gonna do that just let
him get back to writing because he's
probably better at that and that's not
me saying he's a perfect writer my
feelings on him as a writer or a little
mixed but he's definitely got a stronger
track record with that then working as
an executive and it now seems like that
is going to be the case he's going back
to the creative end of things
he's actually kind of being given his
own little company to develop stuff
within with the first look deal I think
is the first look deal might be
exclusive anyways he's he's stepping out
of the executive he's going back to
creative and for him this is a good
thing I think and it because it hasn't
really gotten embarrassing the way
Warner Brothers would trot him out at
geek friendly events or broadcast to
basically be their mouthpiece like I
remember when he and kept like I didn't
even watch this I watched I think
literally 20 seconds of this it was
painful when he and Kevin Smith were
like going through the props from
Suicide Squad and he had to act all
enthusiastic about this garbage fire of
a movie and even before having seen the
movie and realizing how bad the movie
was it was just paint he did not look
like he wanted
be there at all Kevin Smith looked like
he was happy to be there and he seems
really enthusiastic and seemed like he
was really trying to keep the spirit up
but Jeff Jones just he really looked
like he will did not want to be doing
this stuff so I'm glad he's not he's not
gonna have to do that anymore now the
other thing that happened in conjunction
with this is that the person that he
actually answered to a woman by the name
of Diane Nelson she left only about a
week or so ago so not only is he out his
boss is out now neither of these are
firings in Diane's Diane Nelson's case
she was on leave due to a family
situation and just isn't decided she
isn't going to come back and John's as I
said is not like it's not like he's
kicked out and never come back he's just
being shifted somewhere else with
different responsibilities but this
can't help but feel a little bit like a
shake-up all the same especially when
you add on to that the fact that they
put a whole new guy in charge of the DC
films back in January did a whole other
video on that at the time so between all
these things it really does feel like
they're if not doing it deliberately
definitely finding opportunities to
rejigger the executive structure in
regards to DC related properties and I
pretty much every level because Jones's
responsibilities touched on film TV
comics and it was the same with Diane
Nelson now is this a good thing
potentially I forgot himself creatively
I think it's a very good thing for DC as
a whole DC properties DC Comics
I don't know and here's the main reason
why is this effectively leaves the
executive end of DC entertainment and
the comics and specifically in the hands
of Gimli and Dan DiDio Jim Lee is a
wonderful artist I don't particularly
care for a lot of his storytelling
instincts when he does when he is
allowed to sort of get involved with
that more and honestly even even though
I like his art it was one of the things
that was not help that it didn't help
the launch of the new 52 that one artist
got to personally redesign so much of
these characters and suddenly the entire
Justice League had high collars yeah if
I don't I always feel like it was weird
that Jim Lee was put in that position in
the first place again since the guys
known as a artist not a not a writer I
have to wonder and actually I'm gonna
say this is a suspicion I can't back
this up but I have to wonder if they had
wanted Jim Lee to start doing a lot of
the character redesigns for something
like the new 52 relaunch or just in
general and his condition was I want
more say in what goes on overall which
it fits kind of his history he was one
of the guys we left Marvel to help form
image back back in the 90s and he wasn't
he wasn't as petulant about it as some
of those image guys were and he
certainly certainly has a stronger track
record than some of them do like health
but you know him
it's always been weird to me that he's
at the executive level Dan the do I I
don't know why Dan DiDio is still there
Dan to do has
three fixations that I think have been
detriments to DC and their output for
the past I don't know 20 years or so and
those three sort of fixations are
massive events he loves the crisis is
his crises crisis is Zsuzsa
he loves those things and there are too
many and that's not unique to DC Marvel
doesn't - but I know he's big on them
because you know anytime they want
anybody to talk up their next big crisis
event
guess who's who's the biggest
cheerleader he's big into the generally
darker tones and darker stories and
there are good dark stories to be told
but when that becomes so predominant
over the entirety of the line as it has
for DC they things seem to have been
getting a little better lately but for a
while there certainly that was
overpoweringly so and that did bleed
over into the films and I think that's
been not to the betterment of DC as a
whole again that's not me saying you
can't do dark stuff of course you can do
dark stuff but not everything works when
you go dark especially when you've got
so many characters from the gold and
silver age that were literally designed
to be light hearted entertainment to
uplift the spirits of children and yeah
boy and then finally since I mentioned
the Silver Age Dan DiDio has an
obsession with the quote/unquote iconic
versions of these characters that was a
big part of the new 52 initiative
reinstating the iconic versions ie we
don't care what's gone on in the last 30
years or so Barry Allen's now the flash
Hal Jordan is gonna be Green Lantern
Barbara Gordon's gonna be Batgirl and
screwed the continuity and to hell with
the legacy which i think was really dumb
because the history of legacy characters
and mantels being passed
down to you know former sidekicks and
things of that nature was actually I
thought at least one of the stronger
ongoing elements of DC's long-term
storytelling and it was something Marvel
didn't really do yeah dan to do is a guy
I'm not gonna say he did no good for
what his instincts are he has been in
that position too long if somebody was
gonna be shifted out of that executive
position to get to bring in fresh blood
I really wish you it had been him and I
don't have a conclusion to this but I
mean I've been saying for so long you
know Warner Brothers just let Jeff Jones
write comics again and it looks like
they're finally doing that I need to
talk about that and then it you know
spiraled into possible additional
implications and sort of trying to take
a bird's eye view of the whole thing
it's it's like any executive shake-up
could be for the better could be for
worse there's a pretty decent chance
that most folks at the consumer level
won't even notice a difference in which
case why did I even make this video I
don't know how long this has been going
on but I just wasted however much of my
time and yours so you're welcome
and whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it there's all this stuff to
do like and subscribe and support me on
patreon follow me on Twitter links for
all that stuff and more is down in the
description so until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]